[Música]
estas son las noticias de france 24 el
secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken acusó al gobierno de china de
fomentar ciertas condiciones que
facilitan ciberataques para su propio
beneficio
entre estos ataques está el realizado
contra microsoft el pasado mes de marzo
blinken anunció repercusiones contra el
país asiático
ariel henry será el nuevo primer
ministro de haití y encabezará al
gobierno de ese país caribeño henry
había sido ya elegido por el fallecido
presidente juvenil moix un día antes de
su asesinato pero no había sido
investido de manera oficial el nuevo
premier reemplazará a clubs yusef quien
asumirá la cartera de exteriores
con fiestas desde la noche del domingo
los británicos celebraron el día de la
libertad que marca el fin de las
restricciones por la pandemia de kobe 19
la otra cara de la moneda la representa
el primer ministro boris johnson quien
está en aislamiento preventivo por 10
días y pidió a los ciudadanos cautela
con el regreso a la normalidad
muy buenas tardes bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 estamos en vivo
desde nuestros estudios en bogotá en
colombia vamos a comenzar nuestro
continente en el norte en eeuu allí el
secretario de estado de ese país anthony
blinken acusó al gobierno de china de
promover condiciones que facilitan los
ciberataques y también las acciones
criminales en otros países para su
propio beneficio financiero a través de
un comunicado blink en hizo las
acusaciones a las que se unieron también
la unión europea la otan y otros cinco
países que coincidieron en afirmar que
varios piratas financieros apoyados por
chinas son los responsables de
ciberataques a nivel global como por
ejemplo el que padeció microsoft el
pasado mes de marzo el secretario
blinken añadió que habrá consecuencias
contra china por estas acciones que
calificó de irresponsables también el
presidente de eeuu joe biden se refirió
a estos señalamientos escuchemos
tendría un informe mañana en la mañana
un informe detallado según tengo
entendido es que el gobierno chino a
diferencia del gobierno ruso
haciendo esto por sí solo pero está
protegiendo a aquellos que lo están
haciendo
edwin seguimos en el continente
americano ariel henry será el nuevo
primer ministro de haití encabezará el
próximo gobierno de ese país caribeño
tras la renuncia de cloud yusef que a su
vez asumirá la cartera de relaciones
exteriores estos cambios llegan luego de
que varios diplomáticos también la onu y
varios gobiernos de diferentes países no
respaldarán el gobierno interino de
joseph el fallecido presidente joven el
mois había designado a henry quien es un
neurocirujano de 71 años de edad como
primer ministro de ese país justamente
un día antes de ser asesinado y no había
sido investido en el cargo de manera
oficial
federico culé barberena nos cuenta más
en el siguiente informe
las presiones internacionales dieron
resultados y haití se prepara para una
transición de poder el primer ministro
interino cloud yusef dimitirá del máximo
cargo ejecutivo y será reemplazado por
ariel unr y quien había recibido el
respaldo expreso de la onu y de
potencias extranjeras
joseph por su parte integrar al nuevo
gobierno como ministro de relaciones
exteriores a falta de un anuncio oficial
unr y publicó un audio refiriéndose a sí
mismo como primer ministro e hizo un
llamado a la unidad nuestros hermanos
haitianos le dieron una oportunidad de
la paz mientras dejan la posibilidad de
que algún día la verdad pueda ser
restaurada ahora le toca a todos los
líderes nacionales caminar juntos en
unidad hacia un mismo objetivo para
demostrar que son responsables el sábado
el core grupo integrado por los
embajadores de alemania brasil canadá
españa estados unidos francia la unión
europea y representantes de la oea y la
onu había apoyado expresamente anri para
liderar la transición luego del
asesinato del presidente yo en el móvil
el 7 de julio pasado la casa blanca
destacó el inminente pacto político en
haití
no hemos recibido una notificación
oficial a través de nuestra embajada
pero saludamos los reportes de que los
actores políticos haitianos están
trabajando juntos para determinar el
camino a seguir
y había sido nombrado primer ministro
dos días antes de la muerte de maurice
pero no llegó a ser investido por lo que
josep había asumido el ejecutivo
interino el objetivo del nuevo gobierno
será convocar a elecciones en un plazo
que rondaría los 120 días para elegir a
un nuevo presidente
el reino unido- celebró el llamado día
de la libertad con motivo de la
reapertura de los clubes nocturnos y
también el fin del distanciamiento
social debido a la pandemia del cob y 19
los británicos celebraron desde la noche
del domingo y la madrugada del lunes la
reapertura de la vida social y comercial
mientras el primer ministro boris
johnson permanece aislado por 10 días
por haber estado en contacto estrecho
con el ministro de salud que fue
diagnosticado con kobe 19 johnson hizo
un llamado a la cautela
y si no abrimos ahora corremos el riesgo
de tener condiciones aún más duras en
los meses más fríos cuando el virus
tiene una ventaja natural y perdemos el
descanso de las vacaciones escolares
llega un momento después de que muchos
han sido vacunados cuando nuevas
restricciones no van a prevenir más las
hospitalizaciones y las muertes sino que
simplemente van a retrasar lo inevitable
así que tenemos que hacernos la pregunta
si no es ahora cuando la web en francia
las autoridades alertaron sobre la alta
incidencia del coronavirus que aumentó
un 125 por ciento en solamente una
semana según lo comentó el portavoz del
ejecutivo de ese país la tasa de
incidencia en los últimos 7 días es 74
casos positivos por cada 100.000
habitantes frente a los 37 de la semana
pasada lo que representa la progresión
más fuerte desde el inicio de la
pandemia en ese país por este motivo el
consejo de ministro celebró una reunión
extraordinaria
aprobar el polémico proyecto de ley que
hace obligatoria la vacunación contra el
joven 19 para el personal de salud
y en irak ascendió a 35 el número de
muertos y a 60 la de heridos a tras una
fuerte explosión en un mercado de bagdad
la capital de irak y según el reporte de
las autoridades la explosión fue causada
por la detonación de un artefacto de
fabricación casera en un mercado del
barrio de sharp de mayoría chií un
sector que ya en el pasado había sido
blanco de numerosos atentados por parte
de radicales suníes
y esta semana con motivo del inicio de
los juegos olímpicos de tokio 2020
france24 les trae una serie de
reportajes especiales en esta
oportunidad tenemos la historia de paola
pérez una nadadora de aguas abiertas de
nacionalidad venezolana que fue noticia
a nivel mundial hace unos años por casi
sufrir hipotermia en los juegos
panamericanos en lima al competir sin el
traje de neopreno adecuado para este
tipo de disciplinas hoy entrena en
chile- y está haciendo frente a las
restricciones de la pandemia de kobe 19
para buscar un pase a tokio el informe
de patricia luna y adrián
manson
mi nombre es paola pérez soy de
venezuela atleta olímpica en la
disciplina de aguas abiertas me fui a
venezuela porque ya las piscinas no
estaban funcionando y quería seguir
participando en los siguientes juegos
olímpicos
mucha gente se va al país por cuestiones
económicas yo en realidad me fui por una
cuestión de piscina que ya no había
piscinas y ese es mi
me medio por el cual me muevo y eso fue
lo que en realidad me obligó a salir
buscar una piscina donde puedes entrenar
dos veces al día
yo trabajo de clases de natación y
trabajo afecta un poco en mi rendimiento
de entrenamiento a veces el dinero no me
alcanza como tal
gabriel go for me porque no me han dado
el financiamiento que que requiero para
esta preparación
y ya se estaba agotando el tiempo y dije
tengo que buscar la manera es decir
todas las sesiones entrenamiento que
tengo ahora hacerlas a morir de
principio a fin e ir investigando cómo
aprovechar ese tiempo que no tengo en el
agua aprovechando en la tierra y eso
también hace que tenga que estudiar
investigar y apasionarme un poco más de
esto pero desde el punto de vista de
atleti también como de entrenador porque
uno también tiene que hacer como de todo
en este momento
para mí ganar la medalla en los
panamericanos fue una sorpresa pero no
me lo esperaba inclusive cuando toque la
meta dije bueno como de sexto que para
mí quedarse está en un panamericano era
guau y cuando salga mi entrenador como
sollozando y yo por lo que pasó no quedó
de tercero no no me lo podía creer mi
próximo objetivo es el preolímpico que
hay sabré si tengo o no el pase a los
juegos olímpicos de tokio
estoy como un poco a ciegas pero siento
física y mentalmente bien cambiado para
mejor me siento más fuerte más madura
porque para hacer esto también hay que
tener
madurez deportiva pero al final es mi
sueño y yo soy la única que no puede
hacer posible así llegamos al final de
las noticias aquí en france 24 más
información en france 24 punto com
también en las redes sociales y en la
app siga con nuestra programación buenas
tardes
[Música]